hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm jerry so
today we're gonna talk a spoiler
discussion about Mad Max fury road so
before we get into this I was at the
sauna about an hour ago I was hearing
some interesting things about this movie
from a few people debating about it it
was interesting it made me go home and I
was looking up [ __ ] online afterwards
what they were talking about you know
some people are like well it's very
religious and biblical base and one
person's like well it's actually about
breaking away from the system in society
like all these different themes and I
told these guys like I said well this is
exactly what I like the movie because we
get all kinds of conversations coming
from it you know for me personally it's
an awesome thrill ride like that's you
know what I gather from it well that's
the immediate stuff you know and then
you start to pick up on like you know
the more feminist angles of it and stuff
like that women's rights like that's a
thing well I don't mean like there's
that stuff in it and then there is like
you more tanjo like the whole society is
kind of cultish and you know they're
worshipping this guy because he has
access to water and stuff like yeah you
know that I love that because you know
you think you look like a road warrior
where fuel was the main driving power
source and now it's water which makes
them more relatable to modern-day times
things like fuel and water would be the
things you'd kill for in a society like
this you know one thing about these Mad
Max movies I did not catch Beyond
Thunderdome I want to establish that
right but I will say that from watching
three of these Mad Max films I think
it's kind of interesting how they use
max cuz he's not necessarily the main
story part of it neither a road warrior
neither no fury road he's more of a
character device that supports the other
characters well the thing about Mad Max
about mix Rockatansky is his sound like
Bret injure means men maintain the world
is always crazier than he is like you
get the sense that max kind of wants to
be just a guy like he doesn't want any
part of these you know chaotic
easy gangs or these weird societies that
are he's traveling from one place to the
next you know searching for something
you know trying to be free or whatever
the world is always crazier than he is
part of what I love about Tom Hardy in
this movie he just looks so tired he's
like what he's more intense than the Mel
Gibson portrayal yeah like he's a lot
more on edge because Mel Gibson I
noticed like he tended to play
everything pretty cool yeah as opposed
to Tom Hardy's you could see like he
kind of gets frustrating too panics and
so he's more emotional that's what I
like about it cuz you know it's like I
still don't know if this is a reboot or
sequel it feels like a sequel I believe
I read a blurb that said George Miller
basically it's very nebulous like I you
could probably put it into a timeline
with the other ones but he said like
since it's been so long technically
we're rebooting it there's continuity
issues and you know certain people would
be older bla bla bla so technically it's
just another Mad Max adventure but even
the other films are kind of episodic Oh
totally they don't realize this isn't
like Marvel where you need like a
remedial course every time they like if
this is your first Mad Max experience
this can beat your first Mad Max
experience one common complaint I'm
hearing is it's a great action-adventure
movie but there's really no character
like I'm hearing that a lot I've even
seen capsules on Rotten Tomatoes too
that are saying like great action
performances for me personally I walked
away thinking there's no these three
strong character performances in this
movie well yeah I mean you know it's not
it's this is a movie that reveals its
characters everything is really
immediate so like I love that see the
smart thing here is I think is that the
plot itself the driving action is
related to a belief that furiosa has
yeah so that reveals that that gives you
room to reveal stuff about characters
it's not like this average guy was
thrown into a situation but he's got a
family at home the mission is something
that is about belief and is about you
know that's why I enjoy these Mad Max
films is because it's like some
complaints I heard from people outside
of the theater were I wanted to explore
the world and I'm like these Mad Max
movies are not so much about exploring
the world like the world is established
when that max movies do is they find a
plot and George Miller
focuses on that plot and lets the world
be itself what I feel like that makes
these movies bad because the thing about
a lot of like sci-fi
you know post-apocalyptic movies or and
especially the white one getting so hot
up in world exploration that they gotta
get a plot there is always a dude who
comes in and is like you're a normal
person but here's the terminal here's
how everything works
admire movie that just drop down into
the world and you pick up on it yes time
goes by like you said the word immediate
at times I felt like this was a real
time Tet tale yeah that's why when
people say there's no character I'm like
well if you pay attention there is
character yeah like Tom Hardy starts off
and he says like right then and there
that it's all about him being a survivor
yeah like I was talking with someone and
they were like why did him and Charlize
there and have to fight for so long
before they finally came to a conclusion
I'm like whoa because Max is he's a
loner like he he doesn't he doesn't give
a [ __ ] to work with them he just wants
to get the mask off of him and he wants
to take the tank get the [ __ ] out of
there this is a world where a max is
struggling with his own demons from the
past but this is also a world where like
you know one takes two kindly and yeah
you're not inclined to be like hey let's
form an alliance yeah I know I can
exactly like it's dirty as [ __ ] like no
one trusts one another especially woman
in math as if they're going to trust
each other
yeah and so part of this movie is
building trust between furiosa and max
so that he does agree to it to help them
out like I said in C Beyond Thunderdome
so I don't know about Tina Turner's
performance and if it's great or not I
don't from Charlize Theron's that's what
I love it's like it's like how long is
this movie two hours it is a solid two
it's assault like the last man this
would be doesn't two hours when most
action movies now take like two and a
half hours to do mosun
yeah exactly rather than having to feel
like they need to give a lot of
backstory a lot of before a lot of
exposition they let the tail of this a
car chase adventure take care of itself
you can understand these characters
through moments that are not dialogue
you know you get to understand these
characters through how violent they are
like if you look at the main people
escaping you got Charlize Theron Tom
Hardy and the other girls and you could
tell how different they are just from
the action scenes you know you got Tom
Hardy who starts off as a loner a
survivor and then by the end of the film
it is about redemption he's the one who
goes to them he's like hey the place you
were escaping from that's where you can
call home yeah like that is that's got
all the things you need yeah exactly and
Tom Hardy's going to help and get his
Redemption so there's a character arc
and sampling wheel so you gotta keep in
mind this is a version of the world
where there's not a lot to hold on to
like what do people do all day like
there's not a lot for anybody to do
except you know for max just keep moving
yeah you know and then you know he
stumbles across somebody who does have a
goal and a mission you know to break
free of this tyrannical like I like I
think if this movie does well it could
reboot the franchise in a great way
where other people can take over for max
because max like you said is episodic
he's kind of like post-apocalyptic James
Bond oh boy yeah yeah exactly it's like
you don't need you don't have to rely on
the same guy forever yeah he's a war
piece of wanderer who just happens to
stumble upon situations or they need his
help
well then think about - the reason it
doesn't bother me because you know so
many action movies now so many movies
now shoehorn in like that story reasons
to care about people and that's fine but
in this in this movie - I do appreciate
they really captured like the first Mad
Max came out you know sort of in the 70s
and that's a time in cinema where you've
got the sense in a lot of movies that
anything can happen and this is one of
those movies and we don't get those a
lot like you can predict a lot of things
this movie is like these people are all
crazy like yeah this is kind of the
worst instincts of mankind
run amok I don't know who's gonna get
home and what's gonna happen because of
that
you know and it's an interesting
action-adventure because like the first
40 minutes is like jam-packed with
awesome action there everyone's really
talked about what they go through the
stand storm and that whole chase
sequence up and so that's up until that
ended all I heard around the audience
was it like wow it wasn't that it was
like see that was intense there because
his movies kind of like a symphony when
there's that break like when that
movement ends and it fades to black
there was that moment of oh yeah and
then exactly because
it's a different kind of
action-adventure like it's actually
intense it goes beyond low this looks
badass and this is entertaining exciting
it's all that plus a level of fear and
just haunting Menace the whole time
well yeah it's like no no fixer is easy
in this movie and the sandstorm itself
is CG but like a lot of the car chases a
lot of the wrecks a lot of the
arithmetic tell it's practical that's
done men yeah yeah like they really
rigged all this stuff just putting stuff
on screen when you can makes everything
feel more real it makes the stakes
higher it's so much further for San
Andreas before this and the Genesis and
the San Andreas trailer goal is played
in this movie sort of dwarfed what those
do not like because I'm like yes CG
buildings falling is like scary because
your mind fills in the blank but this is
like these cars are wrecking and
exploding and I know it was there but
adds to it is just how little of
protagonist there are yeah you know
there's like very few good people oh
yeah even if you haven't seen the prior
Mad Max films you could see just how
twisted these mines are of everyone
Nicholas Hoult was my favorite part of
this whole movie
really this whole was just the [ __ ]
because I loved how he starts off like
okay he's another crazy Mad Max villain
okay again but then it's like you know
he's a really enjoyable Mad Max villain
so like he loves like and that's part of
what makes these guys also scare is that
they're like they love to fight like
it's all be a primitive and I thought
they took a twist on the villain and as
opposed to how they normally do Mad Max
films like I said I haven't seen third
once I don't know if it's in there but
they took this guy who could have easily
been the crazy character that keeps
playing the cat-and-mouse game that is
always on their tail and it's constantly
going toe to toe max but instead they
flipped it like they started you start
seeing that like this guy is just a
young dude who's like [ __ ]
manipulated and traumatized yeah plus
guy believes he wants to take his place
in Valhalla yeah exactly
exactly anymore tanjo looked at me it
feels even further into the future than
the other Mad Max films the other Mad
Max films it seemed like some characters
were still sort of around went like
maybe older characters were around when
times were not so [ __ ] up yeah now
it's like no one [ __ ] remembers
anything like they're even sane like
everyone had cable that
you know everyone could have their own
television show back then but I mean
everything is just now I know it's so
past tense so that's why it's cool to
see it kind of go back to a sort of
religious ruling rather than you know
just a bunch of crazy gangster cursing
yeah it's it's like another logical
progression everything about this movie
feels like they thought about how to
make it interesting and new again it is
a sequel but they really put effort into
it I gotta appreciate that because you
know it's like if the complaint is now
there's not enough character depth well
think about the movie as a whole though
like the amount of character you get
really matches this movie and it matches
the timeframe it takes place in yeah it
matches the circumstances it matches the
movie itself and so I think this is
great because all the pieces fit
together the proper way not every movie
has to be this character study
necessarily and I think the character
that we get is the proper yeah yeah like
with Nicholas Hoult well I do have a
question like a lego legit question it's
a legal question Nicholas Hoult when he
does transform over to the other side
yeah it did seem a little bit sudden to
me and a little bit fast I will say I
bought it only because I bought his
performance but in terms of like the
writing and timing of all this it was
feeling as something may have been cut
there because like he spent his whole
[ __ ] life going after this and then
within a day or something a few hours
he'd swishes it's a little truncated but
I get what's going on in his head
because it's like he has that whole
thing I'm like I I had through there
were three times today where it's like I
was sure I had it I had my place in
Valhalla and I [ __ ] up all three of
them you know they'll never take me back
now like I'm worthless you know and then
someone actually shows him a lick of
compassion yeah in this world that has
no compassion for anybody for a second I
was like hang on a minute and then well
I feel like I got over it cuz I'm like
well the kids obviously influenced
easily it's not hard for me to go past
that and he's got a purpose again you
know yeah I thought Charlize Theron was
amazing Charlize Theron is [ __ ]
incredible life I think that's a role
that people are not gonna recognize how
great it is because she is so good at it
it seems like she's done that before
you know yeah when she has not know
she's done action movies sure but not
like I'm gonna shave my head I would cut
off my arm me nah man I'm gonna deal
journey what didn't actually cover no
she didn't
she's very method and it is very method
she's like female Daniel they would have
effect a lot of you upcoming role well
know what stem cell research he can grow
back that's the thing about all the
performances I mean Nicholas Hoult and
those the the more villainous characters
get to be bigger and louder I appreciate
both Tom Hardy and Charlize Theron
because so much of their performances
are just in little nuances little looks
and just how they carry themselves and
and their faces and like they really
carry the baggage of the world they're
living in all those little moments
between them is great scenes in it like
after the car chase scene you get the
scene where Tom Hardy's trying to take
over you know like get the mask off in
the chains the way that was all executed
was brilliant this is one of those rare
movies that doesn't need a lot of
dialogue to actually keep the plot
really moving along it's kind of like a
post-apocalyptic Western at times to me
it's like a fast-paced Connecticut I
mean and that's why you get those weird
things it's all primitive it's all older
you know it's like that's why they have
their version of you know they had they
would ride into battle with music and
you've got this crazy dude with a fire
guitar and just droning these heavy
riffs that are really imposing and
creepy and they've got like their
Warpaint's like that it's all very
savage that it's like I saw Mad Max and
then road warrior it gets a budget and
then it's even bigger it's crazier and
then now George Miller returns and he
makes it with all the toy yeah and now
he's like I've seen movies over the past
thirty years I know how to make this
crazy he just makes it [ __ ] it's like
okay it's a great combination of like
keeping current like okay I've studied
it I've seen movies of the past three
years so I know what works there but I
also know it works about the way we used
to do yeah you know it's a perfect blend
of those approaches absolutely the
opening was great you know game you know
he stomps a lizard which is awesome and
then exhaust and then the car chase and
then it's like oh [ __ ] I thought Mad Max
was the badass dude but gets away from
ya
right away I'm glad they got all the fun
cuz I was like I don't wanna watch half
hour with him with like [ __ ] long
hair and a beard well that's a move
that's that right there is your kid like
that's this character's life is moving
from place to place trying to survive
while not being captured and tattooed
against as well like you know all that
[ __ ] and I love how max is not something
that's now someone who's like like what
the hell am I doing here [ __ ] I gotta
break out like he's someone who kind of
goes along waiting for the right
opportunity yeah yeah you know I teach
his place at moment by moment which is
so cool about is all you get yeah I love
what they do is Charlize Theron Skerritt
or to how they didn't set up this whole
backstory with her but they just start
off alright she's leading the mission of
the bad guys and that's all you need to
[ __ ] know at first and then she
starts going her own path I love how it
wasn't like let's show Charlize Theron
for a while and have her do something
bad and then you know let's let's give
her a chance of redemption later on like
they didn't need to set all that up it's
like just let the audience learn that as
it progressed cos you know there's a lot
of badass females in this yeah those old
woman were [ __ ] the [ __ ] those yeah
dude like and I'm soaked was she so this
man went to that old when we got stabbed
I was so sad I know like I was I was
really upset about that I was too I
threw my popcorn at the theater and I
left I didn't finish the movie she comes
back to law I come back so my leaves the
entire community man there's a total -
yeah there's no that's the cool thing is
like as you're venturing away from you
know a more 10 Jose City thing you get
to see the other tribes you know who are
out in this wasteland and and that's
seen it like that was such a great
detail when they go through when it
turns out they went through their
destination that whole marshland with
the dudes s stilts in the crows like
this heartbreaking yeah they're like if
you're here you've already passed the
green player and it's [ __ ] up now Oh
like that's horrible all is lost
yeah no that was really is like
everything save the cat read that book
people know all is lost
one less real save the Catholic you must
read it as like a first screenplay book
and then read it as having a ride no ID
on the screenwriting you'll ever need to
know apply but the young woman were cool
zoe kravitz was awesome yeah well and
that's the thing is like you really got
excited for zoe kravitz the wives that
she's trying to sort of ferry away and
take to safety like they all at a
certain point step up and serve their
purpose the woman are bold you know I
like how the woman also weren't like
[ __ ] like sometimes they're like no
we should we could shield them because
they can't kill us well that's the
things they all work together they're
all people dealing with this situation
and they all have to deal with it and
like you know certain people are
freaking out about like certain men's
rights activists are freaking out about
like the feminist quality of this movie
but it just makes sense it's like yeah
the movie doesn't go out of his way to
go look at how feminist we're being I
just wanna get that at all yeah it's
just it's how this story unfolded it
doesn't stop the movie to go gender
politics you know which is you know it's
a worthwhile argument but it makes it a
piece of the story and doesn't feel the
need to go look at what we did that's
what I love about this is like there's a
lot of pieces in this film what they do
is they take this one chase and they
just put in the right amount of each
piece necessary to complete this the
story if you look back at like the road
warrior the way they set up the road
warrior was like he was a legend and
stuff like at the beginning montage no
Mad Max he was a competent road warrior
they set him up like he oh ya know he's
this legend and we never saw him again
when you got to think about when the
when they tell the stories of this max
legend that they're gonna hop straight
into the adventure you know and then
tell it ends there so I like how these
Mad Max movies also sort of some people
feel they end abruptly but I'm like well
no the adventures done he did it and now
he moves on to the next slide
yeah now he continues searching from
what he's searching for yeah you know
it'll never never stop it's really
depressing really depressing life well
especially this world because that's the
thing is like you see that gang of older
women and your
man maybe you're the ones we should
hello for yes I cuz all these like
different groups of burly dudes are just
not cutting it yeah they're all killing
each other and they're all like doing
terrible things to people and I think
the female touch was nice cuz you got a
bunch of male crazy villains it's cool
adding that female a touch and you know
we're in a day and age in cinema now
where we see a lot more females kicking
ass than usual and I like we should like
you know cuz at the end of the day you
should just treat every character like
this is gonna sound corny but so it's
like every character is just a person
and it shouldn't really matter in a
situation like this it's like yeah you
know she shoots that one dude he shoots
another dude it's like we're all
fighting the same fight you know nobody
needs to be a damsel anymore that's
old-school when it comes to the the
woman that Charlize Theron was
protecting what I love about that is
they could have just been like victims
but you've instead they're portrayed as
survivors you know like they're fighters
yeah you know I mean one of them wants
to [ __ ] out the whole time but the GE
gets her a chance to shine what do you
understand it's like it's not it's it's
not a no something terrifying just
happening what and I'm sure that each of
these wives has a different circumstance
like I mean when the pregnant girl I
mean she was the hottest and she got
killed that was really sad that's the
other thing is like they don't pull
punches no they they went there one
thing I really want to talk about is the
villains motives you know like how he
wants to continue on his legacy of you
know so he's gonna get woman pregnant
and like something with breast milk okay
one thing I like about these bad max
films too is that they're so immediate
that sometimes you don't fully
understand though the why behind
everything yeah but you at least know
what yeah what and everything cuts
different ways just cuz you know you see
that scene where like all these like
pregnant women are being milk yeah
exactly
and it raises you know you you get to
think about the implications of that as
far as the society goes but you also get
to think about like wow this dude's
[ __ ] up man like yeah there's another
extent of the fucked-up-ness of this guy
see I like how they have that one
dude who the guy with the crazy feet and
was fat and he was like telling who's
the main building anymore Tim Joe actor
is that more tan Joe yeah it's like
immortal but with an enemy okay with the
skeleton right now traitor the main
villain the mortal tanjo or something I
liked his most because at one point you
know they even say to him like hey
you've cost us a lot of water a lot of
gasoline the so many people have died
just cuz you want to [ __ ] get some
chicks pregnant and keep the babies it
actually makes it more interesting for
me as they like see like that's his
motive is cuz they fight for different
purposes now now you know in modern day
time sure we'd really like so
financially concerned and logical about
everything but this is much more to this
guy well he's like a general and a cult
leader like his legacy is everything
because if he's stripped of his
imaginary status those people will tear
him apart and his army it's like there
are more unwashed masses than there are
anymore ten Joe's and I just love those
details too because he's like you know
he's an older dude he's got all these
like tumors and stuff and he's like
chubby but he's got this plate with like
all his his rankings that has like a
sixth into it you know this is all an
image yeah it's all an image and he's
ferocious I like how that main bill
because sometimes the main villains like
just telling those other dudes to just
do the job but he was always like going
now that he was always in the field it
was cool to see a character that could
have easily just been a dictator
actually going in like I'm like it just
shows how important this is to him and
how no because if it was about like
you're wasting this you're wasting that
and then he would have been like fine
[ __ ] it let's turn around to see how
much meaning this had to him meant that
he is unstoppable like this nothing
gonna stop him in a place where there
isn't much of a life time
yeah he sends the whole [ __ ] world
like anyone he has at his disposal so
after these guys and it's so cool
because sometimes they get them they get
so far away but they're always in the
distance you know when you feel the
commodity like when they're gas tanker
blows up in the in
Ridge there like the one they were
carrying that's like Oh No like that's a
considerable amount of like what
everyone is fighting yeah exactly I love
when Tom Hardy was at the edge of the
car that Nicolas hold was driving it's
not jam-packed with humor but there's
some interesting you like when he's like
it was funny when he was trying to get
the mask off like well cuz so many times
even if you don't again go into like
huge amounts of backstory it's little
things like that it's like that's a very
human thing it's like this [ __ ] thing
off my head and that becomes just a
little not a subplot but just a little
thing that person asked for a few scenes
where he just wants to get the damn
thing off his head or when he's on the
front of Nick holds car yeah it's like
the dude in the back throwing stuff and
he turns at one point he's like that's
my face yeah please don't take my face
you know those little human moments that
add a lot of humor to this stuff I will
say his voice sounded a little weird
liked a little off if there's one like
if you want a complaint out of me and I
said this in my review - it's like you
know they shot this in a real desert
I'm sure set sound was hard to get so
like some of the ADR is a little iffy
yeah yeah what it seemed off at times
yeah like all the intimations are good
it's just sometimes like the intensity
or like just the amount people are
moving their mouths doesn't quite match
but you know again last thing I want to
say is my faith one of my favorite
moments of this movie was the first 10
minutes after he gets captured and then
he just starts to break away and he's
running through the halls and then he
like jumps onto that crane yeah looking
like oh man that was another moment
where everyone was like wow that's a
perfect balance because it establishes
that like he is formidable but he's not
Superman well it's not super he jumps on
that hook and they [ __ ] get ya they
catch you they catch him again like it's
a dead end he tries but you know no die
like it could have been a conventional
hero who does break away and does some
awesome impossible maneuvers to get the
[ __ ] out of there yeah but the people
that were chasing him were [ __ ] scary
they were a kind of zombie like it's
cool to see that they set up this max
guy is so it reminds me like Indiana
Jones like this guy can get hurt this
guy can get caught yeah he's not
invincible
and he's also just
kind of tie it's like that moment when
the one one of the wives does something
like you know she like ducks in right as
they're about to hit some kind of wall
and he just looks over his shoulder and
he's like yeah it gives her like the
most [ __ ] thumbs up is like that that
reminded me of the moment in Indiana
Jones where he just shoots that one dude
he's he's so tired of this world but
he's like and that was like such a great
little character moment you know Tom
Hardy like probably absorbs everything
like he was probably like well max is
probably also really hungry and
dehydrated yeah you know like Oh Marty's
the kind of girl I won't think about but
I mean you know one day they have said
that like he got into it like he was
very intense good for him good for the
heart anyway guys that's our spoiler
talk from Mad Max fury road if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and we have trailer
reactions and reviews on here movie
reviews solo review shows every few
years we reunite for reading yeah yeah
yeah so look out first whatever view
it's perfect to the Ryan is right Ryan
and is right you're the right thanks I
am on the right and you are on the right
they're left now [ __ ] stay drive outros
nachos